so neubert santos
19 50 i'm slowly working on an opponent
around 2000 on that
myself 18 04
the classic dutchman or also called
india gf ski
ok
looks kind of weird playing
springer the seven so early mostly
on gta c6
springer g5
you want me there  I'm happy to answer
but I can still play springer b6 well
maybe it's a very simple 24
okay that was maybe the idea
somehow
we learn the structures from it here
I am now in groups of 3 and we're enjoying
normal
yes the whole structure of black just
a bit slow in  the development
insofar as
the opening of the exhibition is actually announced that where he can beat me now but I can I can now also here that opens everything
yes I also get speed again right
away on the runners
so well uncertain I
didn’t necessarily beat one
strategically but the five hang
Of course
you could just take it now, but
it's still to be considered whether that's so great
i  st
or whether you maybe only have moves
here
maybe also with the 4
he is of course still not good
three tries again
to make an active development phase
ask where he is going
now maybe thought that you would
continue thome 1 and then dede 15
covers it  isn't springer here either
, than don't have to go after 11 6
yeah that's actually good in the
mood or
yeah now threatened eg 5
yeah that's of course
maybe a good one I would like to have e15
myself of course not really thinking about it now
that's a bit  unpleasant
the 5d
56 or something a bit
stupid black is not so bad so
let's try to continue
if he wins the pawn here
i have to meet your advocate
but maybe also
springer c4
so the question is maybe even
wintour and
the villages  3 still
yes of
course even more difficult position
somehow I would also like to have a
little more time
yes e  it's still a bit
uncomfortable
oh I haven't seen here yet I
've only thought about springer
god oh god oh god no
oh how stupid how stupid
well
for nothing less
yes he was right
thum who used to serve
when I still completely feeds a  3 d 6
maybe you can still try something
a little
bit
I would like to come here and not
like but
and yes the six I think
even more of a demonstration than
what really brings
satteldorf
38 somehow still has it ne  can
yes
there can yes then second who was once so
embarrassing
yes
now has seen that where one that was
expensive so expensive what not at all but about
what was allowed
yes source one should not set
but
somehow yes eh
544 I need
something what is your good actually
white should be good
there can always do something like 5
maybe I just have to do
bc and on e5 then someone else
there was somehow not  so clear everything